nathan ivaldi will be taking the mound
for the boston red sox here tonight we
talked about his last start against the
ray struggled a little bit the most
recent start against the blue jays he
gave up seven earned runs in four and
two thirds so over his last two starts
10 innings pitch 13 runs 12 earned both
losses and for boston to start to try
and turn this thing around they're going
to need a big effort tonight from nathan
evaldo
with a cut and miss
he is out on strikes to start this one
i'll tell you what five pitches in and
ivaldi pretty sharp with the stuff the
fastball saw a couple of breaking balls
and a couple of splits and that
curveball right there getting underneath
the swing of brandon for out number one
one up one down for g-man choi their
star last night certainly one of them
2-2
set him down big number one there at 97.
boy it's impressive back-to-back
punch-outs one with a curveball
and split-fingered followed by some hair
right there that ball is right by him
with aldi whines and deals fastball hit
in the air
to center field jaron duran a few steps
in to make the catch and of aldi has an
easy one two three first inning on 15
pitches the tampa bay rays here tonight
it's going to be left-hander josh
fleming making his 11th start of the
season 19th overall appearance
ninth wins looking for win number 10 the
era 4.12 he's won his last two starts
talked about that start against the
boston red sox his last timeout 10 base
runners in five innings eight hits and a
couple of walks but able to to keep the
damage to a minimum picked up a win in
that game
that's hit toward the alley that's a
clean shot onto the grass and up against
the wall
[ __ ] digging into second base
and a nice start for the sox tonight as
he rips a double that's that extra
baseman that machine had it going on for
a good month and he whistles this cutter
into the gap so fast rbi opportunity
right away for hunter renfro who's out
of the two hole tonight fleming works
out of the stretch from the first time
line drive base hit down the right field
line and heading for the corner by the
pesky pole hernandez around to score as
it's played back in by a rose arena and
it's a stand-up double for hunter renfro
red sox with back to back two base hits
renfro went up there swinging at the
first pitch boguard's hitting 305 16
homers
and that's hit hard to center field
retreating is the center fielder
phillips and it's over his head
into the 420 marker all the way into the
triangle it'll be the third straight
double and ren throws around to score
the red sox lead two to nothing they've
come out swinging three straight doubles
and the rbi for bogarts is 57th and the
two base hit is his 31st one behind the
american league leader marcus simeone of
toronto and we'll bring up jd martinez
base hit
randall dove and came up empty another
run in
bulgaria will score and the red sox take
a three nothing lead in the first inning
and jd has rbi number 72 of the season
once again a pit's not much on it and
these balls are cutting right there ball
should be crushed he gets on top of it
now kevin plowacki swinging a ground
ball too short could be two franco to
second for one loud detroit double play
the rays turn it 6-4-3 and they're
swinging early and it worked mostly for
boston that inning until right at the
very end detective double play ends a
troublesome first at the end of one
and he hits another smash this one over
the head of the third baseman joey
wendell into the left field corner
dalbeck around second coming into third
he'll be held at third and [ __ ] has
another double so he has two doubles in
his many innings the red sox have five
hits four of them doubles they had three
straight doubles to start the game red
sox already with four doubles off
fleming second and third two down
driven down the line there's another one
all the way to the monster two runs will
score dull back in hernandez and another
double for hunter run fro pretty well
hit line drive with a loop in it and he
has four extra base hits already in the
series he doubled and homered last night
he has two doubles tonight
meadows hits the first pitch in the
shallow left field long run and it's big
caught by denver's with his back to home
plate marwin gonzalez came charging in
and raffi took charge and with his back
the home plate made the catch over the
head to retire the side fleming's gonna
have to work his way through rafael
devers though he's over two with a
couple of ground downs one to third and
one to first
here's the swing of the line drive down
the left field line hits on the grass
it's going to roll all the way to the
wall here comes [ __ ] to score rent throw
to third he's held there by carlos
fables it's an rbi double for raffy and
it's a six-nothing red sox lead we're
happy with the 84th rbi ripping the
bullet as he went with a pitch away and
lined it to left red sox have knocked
him around the tune of six runs nine
hits here's the 3-0
and he's going to walk in a run here
comes another one renfro jogging home
and rbi the easy way for plawiki is
ninth marwan gonzalez is the batter
a little blue into right rosarina coming
on it dunks down for a hit devers is in
jd to third plucky to second then an rb
ahead for marwyn gonzalez
and still no move from cash and his
bobby dalbeck who has been walked two
times once intentionally
he goes the other way and barely gets
the outfield grass martinez is in
here comes the second run throw to the
plate
and plawecki is in took them forever to
get the ball back in the infield that
looked like a one run hit that loicky
was very much content to stop at third
instead it's ten nothing red sox baldy
working out of the stretch comes set
just above the belt in his pitch swung
on and missed
good cutter for strike three just above
the knees two more strikeouts in the
inning for nathan of aldi we're in the
middle of the fifth at fenway first hand
second with one away in front of jd
martinez who's having a good night just
about everybody is he's two for two of
the walk shot in the right field a base
hit
xander will score easily and that's a
three-hit game for jd martinez he's been
on it red sox up 11 nothing in the fifth
swing and a high fly ball not deep in
right
arose arena started in now he's
backpedaling and in trouble and he does
not catch the ball
two runs have scored three runs will
score and dalbeck winds up at third
three more runs score on what appeared
to be a routine fly ball brandon lau in
the leadoff spot tonight he is over two
that's a shot into right field that's
well town and that's gonna go
home run
renfro watched it sail out and brandon
lau gets the rage on the board for their
first run of the night baldi had made
only 78 pitches through six innings but
despite having nine strikeouts 2-2
popped up
flowecky long run for our ooze
[Music]
last second adjustment and able to make
the catch
rose arena has popped up and struck out
2-2
past him
he struck him out back to the cutter oh
that's nasty that cutter that's number
ten ten that's a big number left-hand
batting joey wendell swings and drives
went pretty well to center field back
goes duran but he has the room and makes
the catch at the edge of the warning
track to retire the side what a job by
avaldi just three hits in seven innings
if that's it so francisco mejia who
started to catcher will take over on the
mound in a 14-1 game
there's a high deep drive
that one way way gone
over everything
for xander it's the one thing the red
sox attack had lacked tonight until now
is the home run
phillips has a grand slam on this road
trip he already has two for the year
he swings and it's a high fly ball back
into deep left field and that ball is
gone
a grand slam
for brett phillips he went the opposite
way and hits his third grand slam
of the season
into the shift that ought ended
and that will indeed the red sox win the
ball game going away 20-8 the final
score